parce que non tout ne coûte pas un bras
quand on fait de la vidéo il ya des
astuces de la bricole du système d et
des petits accessoires hyper sympathique
que moi j'utilise quasiment tous les
jours qui coûte pas très cher et qui
sauve un petit peu la vie qui sauve un
petit peu des tournages qui font gagner
en confort tout ça et on va en parler
mais juste après l'intro
et salut à tous les amis c'est françois
pour la chaîne explique mans encore je
suis ravie comme à chaque fois comme
toujours comme pour chaque vidéo de vous
retrouver encore une fois fidèle au
poste de plus en plus nombreux tout ça
et si vous êtes nouveau sur la chaîne et
bien sachez qu'ici on parle de caméras
on parle de tournage on parle de montage
vrai de faire des vidéos donc si c'est
quelque chose qui vous intéresse vous
pouvez envisager de cliquer sur le petit
bouton s'abonner
voilà la cloche toussa toussa toussa il
n'était pas à me suivre sur instagram
aussi il ya des story il ya du be and
the sign à des astuces il ya des trucs
tous les projets en cours ils sont sur
instagram donc avalisé
aujourd'hui je vais vous présenter cinq
petits accessoires vraiment pas cher qui
vont vous aider un petit peu dans votre
tournage pour pas se prendre la tête
tous ses accessoires dont je vais vous
parler ce sont des accessoires que
j'utilise au quotidien que j'ai acheté
avec mes petits sous
donc ce n'est pas une vidéos
sponsorisées je ne suis pas payé pour la
faire bla bla bla bla tout ça voilà
c'est juste entre vous et moi c'est
cadeau alors sans plus tarder on y va
premier accessoire c'est parti alors ce
qui est plus important de tous si tu le
truc le plus important quand on fait de
la photo de la vidéo c'est la lumière
pouvait avoir la meilleure caméra du
monde si la lumière est pourri la vidéo
la photo est pour rien c'est voilà et
niveau petit accessoire lumière vous en
avait parlé dans une précédente vidéo
moi j'utilise une petite led sur
batterie de la marque moman
elle est super utile pour un petit
éclairage d'appoint pour déboucher des
ombres pour filmer des produits
éventuellement ça m'arrive aussi et même
là en l'occurrence je m'en sers de
backelite donc cette petite light elle
est très très fine elle fait quoi un
centimètre d'épaisseur grand maximum la
batterie à pleine puissance on peut
espérer une petite heure d'autonomie
donc c'est plutôt cool
on peut régler l'intensité on peut
régler la température se lance y ont vu
une lumière plus chaudes ou plus froides
elle se recharge en usb c'est elle
rentre dans la poche et prend aucune
place enfin vraiment c'est le petit
accessoire que j'ai toujours dans mon
sac quand je pars en tournage parce que
on sait jamais ça peut toujours servir
il ça m'a sauvé la vie pas mal de voix
parce que juste pour déboucher des
petites ombres sur un produit à filmer
ou sur un endroit où il va juste manqué
un tout petit peu de lumière ou alors
d'un endroit où j'ai pas la possibilité
d'amener une grosse light comme celle
que j'ai là par exemple ça va pouvoir
dépanner est passé de très très bonnes
qualités ça marche bien
pourquoi s'en priver c'est le coût de 49
euros voilà c'est un truc dans le sac
franchement c'est cool le deuxième
accessoires c'est quelque chose que je
me suis mis à utiliser il n'y a pas très
longtemps que j'ai découvert il n'y a
pas très longtemps alors que ça existe
depuis belle lurette mais j'avais pas
forcément l'idée de m'en servir c'est le
clan peut fixer à un bras magique alors
tout simplement ce club c'est une petite
pince avec une petite vis pour le sert
et on peut l'accrocher n'importe où et
on peut surtout avec le petit bras
magique est fixé n'importe quel
accessoire petit accessoire
là en l'occurrence pas toujours ici là
backelite elle est fixée sur la tige en
métal de l'armoire et ça me permet
d'accrocher cette light n'importe où ça
m'arrive également de fixer un
enregistreur sonore le petit h1n que
j'utilise bas on peut l'accrocher à une
table
à n'importe quoi en fait on peut
vraiment c'est ça se fixe à n'importe
quoi donc c'est vraiment pas mal
on peut également y accrocher un
moniteur pourquoi pas si on a un
moniteur déportés et ça coûte 20 balles
voilà donc c'est le genre de truc pareil
dans le sac
ça servira toujours la seule chose c'est
que le bras magique qui est fourni avec
c'est un petit bras magique un petit
bras à rotule articulé selon le poids de
ce que vous avez fixé dessus bon
généralement c'est une petite pince donc
on ne fixe pas des grosses choses avec
mais ça vaut peut-être le coup d'avoir
un petit bras magique un peu plus
costaud il en existe de différentes
tailles pour différents poids donc à
vous de voir en fonction des accessoires
que vous voudrez y fixer le troisième
accessoires qui est aussi parmi les
indispensables et surtout les très très
très pratique et peu cher c'est la
poignée pour votre appareil alors moi
j'en utilise une qui se fixe sur une
cage mais il existe des poignets qui se
fixe à la griffe de l'appareil photo ce
qui va permettre de tenir avec cette
poignée l'appareil par dessus pourquoi
c'est intéressant parce que ça va vous
donner une stabilisation supplémentaire
parce que quand on est en mouvement et
qu'on tient là pareil c'est très
difficile de rester relativement stable
ici on va pouvoir le tenir par lé dessus
et par un effet mécanique c'est de la
physique avec de la gravité et un ni
plus ni moins on a quand même une
stabilité qui est vachement intéressante
avec ça le fait de pouvoir aussi tenir
bien fermement l'appareil quand on s'en
sert pas quand on se le trimballe c'est
vraiment hyper intéressant neuf fois sur
dix dans les huit fois sur dix ça
m'évite de sortir un game boy ça n'a
rien à voir avec un plan stabilisé avec
un stabilisateur on est bien d'accord ça
reste manuelle mais très souvent
j'arrive à faire ce que je veux de façon
relativement stable simplement avec la
poignée avec ce ce petit système cette
petite astuce en rajoutant un peu de
stabilisation en post-production quand
on est sur du run and gun qu'il faut
aller vite
bah ça permet d'avoir des plans quand la
mission assez bien stabilisé encore une
fois je le répète c'est pas du niveau
d'un stabilisateur
mais pour le prix ça a rien à voir ça
s'équilibre pas il n'y a pas de batterie
ya pas de quoi que ce soit voilà encore
une fois dans le sac
ça mange pas de pain est la mienne je
les prises chez small rythme et il ya
plein de marques qui font ce genre de
choses donc vraiment là aussi faites
votre choix toute façon je mets dans la
description les liens vers
ce que j'ai moins le quatrième
accessoires c'est un petit peu
particulier parce que celui là je ne
vais pas en ma possession tout
simplement parce que je me suis bricoler
un équivalent avec de l'existant je vais
vous montrer mais vous pouvez acheter
directement l'accessoire en question et
cet accessoire c'est un petit trépied à
rotule manfrotto alors il vient se
glisser sur le petit peu de vie ce qu'il
ya sous votre caméra il va avoir
plusieurs fonctions la première fonction
est bien que ça va être de servir de
trépied comme son nom l'indiqué voilà ou
révélation et donc est ce que je disais
je sais plus avec sa petite rotule on va
pouvoir l'incliner un petit peu comme on
veut donc ça peut servir pour la photo
ça peut servir pour tout simplement
aussi un petit mouvement de caméra qui
peut être sympa en rade sol ou si on a
de quoi le poser en hauteur ça peut
clairement vraiment de dépanner et puis
surtout c'est tout petit c'est hyper
compact et l'autre fonction c'est que ça
va faire aussi également une poignée
supplémentaire cette fois ci en dessous
pour du blog par exemple quand on est en
train de se filmer quand on filme la
caméra en face on n'a pas besoin de se
trimballer le gorille la peau tout le
monde avait un gorille la mode avant et
puis moi je sais que j'utilise quasiment
jamais maintenant je n'utilise quasiment
plus parce que en fait entre les les
pâtes qu'il faut bien mettre qui se dé
qui se décline avec le temps enfin dans
ses chiens donc ça je trouve ça beaucoup
plus utile et puis le combo poignet du
dessus pony du dessous niveau
stabilisation c'est plutôt cool et
généralement je m'en sers aussi pour
faire des effets vortex faire des
petites rotations de caméras sans avoir
à sortir le gumball encore une fois donc
là on est vraiment sur quelque chose
d'assez pratiques pareilles on est un
petit coup de stabilisation après en
post prod ça vaut pas un mouvement de
game boy mais l'encombrement il est
minimal et la prise de tête elle est
minimale aussi donc ça coûte 30 bal
c'est manfrotto qui fait ça là aussi
dans le sac pour ça j'ai toujours ce
truc là et c'est plutôt cool et moi ce
que j'ai fait c'est que j'utilisais la
rotule demong rue la mode qui fonctionne
très bien et j'ai utilisé le petit
trépied de mon vieux ayoun craignent 2
que j'évite ses dessous
et ça me fait exactement la même chose
que ceux manfrotto et j'ai pas déboursé
un centime donc si vous avez un vieux
gorille la pod et
de petit trépied de stabilisateur pouvez
aussi vous bricoler ce truc là ça coûte
rien du tout enfin le dernier qui est un
petit peu à part parce que oui le titre
c'est cinq accessoires à moins de 50
euros bon cet accessoire là il est un
tout petit peu plus cher que je me
voyais pas trop en fait faire un titre
du style 4 accessoires à moins de 50
euros est un accessoire à moins de 80
euros non ça c'est donc que donc voilà
dont il est un tout petit peu plus cher
mais il reste très abordable ce dernier
accessoire c'est tout simplement une
cage que j'ai sur mon appareil ici c'est
une small ring alors cajou 2000 cage et
ça on va dire que c'est l'accessoire
ultime
pourquoi l'accessoire ultime parce que
tous les accessoires dont on vient de
parler ici on va pouvoir venir les fixer
directement sur cette cache donc sur
l'appareil va pouvoir ajouter une lite
on va pouvoir ajouter un micro aura pour
ajouter les bras magique avec ce que
vous voulez autour on va pouvoir
rajouter les poignées dessus en fin de
prêt qu'on va pouvoir venir tout fixé
dessus et c'est un petit peu le graal en
fait en termes d'accessoires puisque
c'est la base qui va vous permettre de
customiser à loisir votre caméra en
fonction de ce que vous faites c'est
même arrivé de fixer une petite power
banque dessus pour alimenter carrément
l'appareil un jour où je vais shooter
pendant très longtemps
faut pas avoir à changer les batteries
la niveau imagination vous pouvez
vraiment vous faire la caméra que vous
voulez à partir de votre mirrorless de
votre caméra hybride vous pouvez partir
dans tous les sens c'est vraiment
rajouter ce que vous voulez petit
inconvénient forcément quand on
customise comme ça quand on pilote un
petit peu sa caméra bah forcément sale
alourdissent est à prendre en compte
aussi tous ceux rig qu'on va faire
autour de la caméra salle alourdit donc
on perd un petit peu le côté run and gun
de l'hybride mais on va lui rajouter
mais grave dans sa race des
fonctionnalités on va pouvoir avoir une
caméra de compet quoi je vous parle même
pas si on rajoute l'atome au second tout
en coraux et tout ça va faire la sale
truc de fou truc de fou et voilà les
amis on a fait le tour de ses cinq
accessoires voulais retrouver en lien
dans la description s'il y en a que vous
pensez qu'ils sont intéressants pour
vous j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura
plu si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à
mettre le traditionnel celui que le
monde entier nous envie le coup de
blaster sur le pouce en l'air qui situe
juste en dessous de cette vidéo pensez à
vous abonner si ce n'est pas déjà le cas
à activer la cloche partagé cette vidéo
fait du bruit c'est hyper important on a
proche des 50 mille abonnés sur la
chaîne c'est juste une dinguerie mais
total voilà c'est un truc de fou
je prends toujours autant de plaisir à
vous répondre dans les commentaires donc
n'hésitez pas à me laisser des petits
messages à poser vos questions a suggéré
aussi d'autres accessoires auquel
j'aurais peut-être pas pensé
et puis en attendant moi je vous dis
rester curieux et à très bientôt pour
une prochaine vidéo faut toujours rester
jusqu'à la fin 1 ça vous le savez les
vrais de vrais reste jusqu'à la fin et
ça et que là quand même
je suis un petit peu en train de me
poser la question si je vais pas faire
du full time you tube
je me pose la question je suis pas prêt
psychologiquement à le faire mais je
commence à l'envisager
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez
j'aimerais bien avoir votre avis je pose
salah puis je dis ça je dis rien on
verra